[Music]
I think I just really um laughed at the
uh maybe non-intentional pun in this
article
title Florida Villages man the area is
called Villages uh charge in Viagra
smuggling operation faces hard
time what a good what a good TI I saw
that one I like is there something soft
time is under a year hard time over a
year I don't know man it's a pun I was
just talking about I get the I
understand he wants to know the
technical term of hard time why don't
you explain it soft I know is there soft
time right well if there's hard time
there has to be soft time you know how
dicks get hard right not really
okay [__] get hard am I right let's
go [__] sh gets rock hard dilate a
clitoris I know dude I know so a
77-year-old Villages man named Reginald
kiner is facing prison time for running
what can only be described as a black
market for erectile dysfunction drugs I
think Florida's a great place for that
cuz there a lot of retirees and senior
citizens there another place I'd
recommend would be Hawaii and Las Vegas
Hawaii Las Vegas has old people and it
uh it's a big bodybuilding drug as well
oh cuz steroid guys they like viles oh
so guys are on SW get the p aalis you'll
catch a pump you'll get a crazy pump so
you get a boner while you're lifting I
think if you're looking at some ass
maybe Sager where it's hot that's my
little hot tip out there sell it where
it's hot I had to turn the [__] AC
down the other night cuz I was like baby
I can't do anything until this thing
gets colder in
here tropical zones I think so that's
true though but I feel like tropical
cultures everyone's hard run hot
backwards I run hot yeah but like ice
water makes your pee yeah but I run hot
yeah he's like a viking where he's one
with the cold so then when it's cold
he's like hard time and then like it's
Kryptonite for the heat he's like it's
too hot I love the cold I'm olymp dick
it's hot exactly that's why you moved to
Vegas correct but it gets cold in Vegas
it does I agree in December it's [__]
chilly BR Vegas brings it on both ends
right if Vegas going to bring it it's
going to bring it hot if Vegas going to
bring it it's going to bring it C it's
very intense it always brings but I love
it it's going to bring it hard cuz I get
to wear jackets for once yeah true I had
to buy a
jacket cool hard Florida man so what
else about the new hard old man have you
guys ever tried bagra never have you you
I'm scared cuz some people take it like
a party drug I heard that like if you
don't have erectile dysfunction and then
you take it it [__] up makes me scared
of I'm afraid of it but some some people
they'll like do a little bit of coke
maybe take half a pill and they just
want to party around and see what
happens all I do I don't know if this is
actually what Viagra does but I don't
touch myself for a week and then it's
party time what if you got to wash your
dick damn I didn't think about that son
of my own [__] I [__]
cheated cuz I clean it thoroughly and
it's probably jacking off yeah damn it
yeah I have seen random YouTube clips
about guys that pranked their homies and
like give them VI you guys seen those
ones oh no that what happened what if
they got a heart issue or something
you're going to kill a homie dude what
they got blood [__] but but how do they
how did they how did they prank how did
they put it in there was one dude who
just like somehow got his homie to take
yeah somehow got his homie to take
Viagra and then they had to go go like
run some errands and this guy's like
wearing just like heather gray [__]
sweatsuit by the way right and then
they're just like you walking around
doing stuff but every now and then he's
like he's just kind of like holding it
down you know and honestly this guy got
a big Big John oo so it's like you can
kind of see YouTube video yes it was on
YouTube were you impressed how big is
Big I was cracking up were you was your
mouth watering AIT 3 in 3 in do you feel
do you feel jealous of men with big
dicks yeah I mean
no I'm not insecure about it okay I'm
not jealous but I'm in awe wow are you
curious to see what it feels like in my
hand I wanted to touch and see St just
hung he has a big dick I heard he's 6'4
Nikki said it's I don't know if it wors
like that is it I bet I bet it's not
like that what theu said it's like this
not like that what the [__] what is it
like then Steve show me what it's like
like the rep bottle it's not like the
rep bottle real thick at the bottom two
hands big oh dude he's 6'4 bro sh the
[__]
up Salute yeah next time a salute a
man's man right there dude I want to be
stupid the other day I went he can you
throw it over my shoulder see how goes
down the other day I went to go ride
horses and I saw horse pee and I said
maybe Steve is that big those things are
crazy all animal [__] for some reason
like a soft baton have you
seen hey I don't want to brag but my
dog's dick very big bro really why you
looking over there cuz he got a red
rocket and when it's red rocket you're
like wao dude that's the biggest red
rocket I've ever dog penis is like
lipstick have you seen elephant dick y
you're crazy elephant right it's like as
big as sound M bigger dud my body B and
as long as their legs and they can use
it to like scratch their bellies and
stuff they use it to scratch their belly
that's kind of use it there's utility to
it outside are they scratching their
belly or they just jacking off my penis
couldn't reach my belly even if I
stretched it out dude not even if you
got take a coup not even I was upside
down not even I was upside down dude
this morning I was watching a monkey
jack off to visitors at the zoo that's
cool and then the visitors like what is
he doing oh he's a bad monkey and he was
jacking off and he [__] sprayed it
all over the window and I was like
that's a lot of jizz he [__] a lot of
he [__] shot up the window and then
he [__] sucked his own dick after it
just can we Photoshop Joe talking to a
kindergarten this morning I was watching
a monkey jack off to visitors at the zoo
and then the visitors like what is he
doing oh he's a bad monkey and he was
jacking off and he [__] sprayed it
all over the window and I was like
that's a lot of jizz he [__] a lot of
he [__] shot up the window and then
he [__] sucked his own dick after
it there were kids in the zoo they pan
back to the kids and they like back to
the kids like sitting Indian St like the
[__] and one of them just
goes like that's a lot of
C wow hey Ryan clip this dude there was
there was so much C I didn't believe
that was all up in that monkey's nut
that was the first video you watched
this morning no it wasn't the first but
I it was in my [__] algorithm the
first one I was I was watching elephant
dick scratch his belly no the other one
is did you know African elephants are
pretty mean I saw a clip of Joe Rogan
talking about um elephants with this
other guy I think it was that Brian guy
from The Fighter and the kid okay but
then like this there's a footage of a
elephant going up and [__] up a water
buffalo for fun oh [__] and his dick did
nothing okay nothing scratch his belly
up and then right after that he swiped
and then there's this monkey right just
cranking
one yeah little kids are like like M
than the monkey dude when I feel most
like Joe it's when I'm watching monkeys
smoking cigarettes and stuff like that
and I'm howling I'm just laughing so
hard and I'm looking for the next one
the next little hit I can get that's
when I feel the most like Joe I always
think of Joe when I'm
doing my animal videos are slightly
different is it just animals Nature's
metal yeah yeah yeah that or like animal
too dude
I have that and golden retrievers
pretending like they're humans I like I
got a lot of dog videos M the most
recent one that blew my mind was a a a
gazelle eating a snake did you see that
one a gazelle yeah it went up to a snake
it grabbed it and they started chomping
on it and I was reading the caption it
was talking about how like you know even
in nature even though they're herbivores
in nature when they need to survive
people will do whatever they need to or
animals will do whatever they need to do
wonder if that's how we became omnivores
uh I've heard this I heard if you died
at home uh and your body's there no one
finds you like your cat will start
eating you like no like within like a
day well cats don't give a [__] but dogs
dogs I think it's a week and then they
might they're like oh I'm so hungry I
have to do it smart and they know that
they don't want to rotting yeah I heard
I heard cats will eat you within a day
bro cats don't give a [__]
about do I'll fight you I'll literally
fight you you literally die for this Joe
yeah not my cat my cat's like a dog
you'll love them shut the [__] up cat
lovers hon get a dog get a dog when I'm
done working my phone's like a [__]
game boy well then I'd buy a Game Boy
not a phone when I'm done when I'm done
working out you're the first ass I
kick remember even in Egypt cats were
Gods dogs were pets cats are fine I'm
not saying that they're not but
everyone's excuse when they say like no
no no but my cat it's like a dog I think
you I think you should get both get a
dog both dog I had a dog cuz dogs are so
[__] you can't even leave town can't
go to JK or nothing because guess what I
got a stupid dog can't even go to JK I
got a I got a dog who got to be out [__]
you know how it is B you got a [__]
babies at these things I found out about
the pooch hotel in Vegas you could bring
dogs here it's okay there a Pooch Hotel
there's a pooch hotel if you want to
bring a dog bring a dog I'm going to
bring two can I bring two yeah we always
we've been telling you to bring your
[__] P me don't yell at me okay I'm
afraid they're going to start barking
and it's going to be a problem okay yeah
don't BR [__] dogs they're they're
they were good the whole time they
chilled on us and [__] for whole SES
you're supposed to bring them yeah we
like it okay I'll bring them see even
the cat people support dogs here whereas
dog people [__] haters this guy's a
douche we're going to my dog's like a
cat what do you think about lizard
people though no that's like all the all
the red flag jokes is so real like any
Chick any chick that has a pet snake or
lizard or something I'm never dating you
that's a swipe dude it's also like it's
the same people who have VHS still and
like oh but like it's like pretty it's
like no no no you don't understand the
tape look like they're they're going on
some type of like Amazonian Adventure
when they live in the suburbs yeah weird
weird ones that get into like poisonous
[Music]
snakes
a